what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcm we
just watched hawkeye episode four so
needless to say some spoilers coming for
episode four this is going to be my
breakdown of the episode but i actually
am going to hit you with some big
theories as well i think i might have
discovered who the true villain is and i
think i figured out that they're making
us believe that certain people are the
villains when they really aren't and i'm
also going to hit you with a theory
about who that watch that rolex could
belong to and maybe some of you are
thinking it but maybe some of you aren't
and the answer might surprise you if my
theory is correct so we're going to talk
about all of that in this video and of
course if you love marvel be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the recent mcu news so a lot
happened in hawkeye episode four there
are some key things that we need to talk
about and let's start off by talking
about and breaking down jack and eleanor
now the last episode we left off on a
cliffhanger with jack holding the ronin
sword to hawkeye's throat telling him
not to move and this is exactly where we
pick up now jack thought that hawkeye
was an intruder but they quickly
realized that it's hakai and even though
he calls him archer he definitely
recognizes who he is an avenger so the
two of them sit down with eleanor and
jack and kate comes on pretty strong
about the fact that the two of them are
working together eleanor is surprised
saying that her daughter is helping an
avenger with an avenger level threat in
which hawkeye says not exactly but
ultimately admits that they are working
together eleanor figured out that kate
used her security clearances to try and
locate some information about the
tracksuit mafia but ultimately says that
she'll have to trust everybody at the
table which is ironic because i'm about
to explain why she's the bad guy but she
escorts hawkeye out alone and she
explains that kate isn't a superhero
clinton says i know but she's pretty
good in which eleanor says natasha
romanov was pretty dang good at it
wasn't she and this really hits clint
right in the fields he gets pretty torn
up about this as you can tell by the
expression on his face and later on when
he talks to kate about it and has
flashbacks of natasha we can tell that
he's just still really really emotional
but eleanor wants clint to not put his
daughter in danger and he told her that
he can't leave the case alone but it's
very interesting she asks him to close
the file on the case she says so you'll
forget this case and of course clint
can't do that he is on a mission and
here's where things get kind of
interesting i've stated from the
beginning that i don't really think jack
could be the villain because i think
it's too obvious i think it's too much
in our face and i think here it's
starting to get revealed who the true
villains are they introduced kingpin in
the last episode not directly but we did
see him and we did find out that there
is somebody above maya and as soon as
clint leaves the bishop's apartment
eleanor gets right on the phone and
makes a call the person doesn't pick up
but she leaves a message saying um it's
eleanor could you call me back please
it's urgent and she's stuttering this
whole time and gasping for air so she's
clearly very concerned now here's
exactly what i think is happening here i
think eleanor is a bad guy i think she's
a villain and i think she's working
either for or with kingpin now you may
be thinking but didn't they reveal in
this episode that jack was actually kind
of involved with the tracksuit mafia and
yes they did reveal that however i don't
think it's what it seems to be now i
actually really like jack i think he's a
good character and i think he's actually
a good guy i think he's a good guy who
is simply in love and i think he's just
a guy who really likes swords now
hawkeye's wife laura finds out that jack
is the owner of a holding company that
launders money for the tracksuit mafia
apparently revealing that he works with
them but let's recall what arman said in
the first episode in the first episode
he was very very skeptical of eleanor he
said that he tried to convince jack not
to marry her he said jack thinks he won
the lottery but he wasn't sure about
that then we saw him arguing with
eleanor and his words were i have
powerful friends too meaning eleanor was
talking about and using as leverage her
powerful friends who i believe is
actually kingpin i believe that's who
she called when she made that call
saying that it's urgent with obviously
the urgency being that clint barton and
avenger is now on their case then if you
recall armand said in the auction that
jack doesn't have any money he said that
he didn't have the 300 grand to pay for
the sword which leads me to believe that
jack isn't exactly as smart as they're
trying to make him appear i think
eleanor is using jack in the words of my
moderator for the channel mr anderson i
think he is a patsy i think he's
charming but i don't think he's smart
and this is actually proven in the scene
after he dances with eleanor he says you
know what they say life is short you
never know what you're gonna get which
is part of an actual saying but is also
part of forrest gump's mother talking to
him when she says life is like a box of
chocolate you never know what you're
gonna get which is why eleanor and kate
immediately burst into laughter and kate
says every time you use one of those
aphorisms they are wrong and he just has
no clue he says no that can't be right
is it but then eleanor says the other
day you said absence makes the heart
grow older which is wrong the actual
saying is absence makes the heart grow
fonder and he genuinely doesn't know
that these are the wrong sayings so i'm
starting to think that he's just not a
very smart guy and he's lovestruck which
makes it incredibly easy for eleanor to
use him which is why i think she
actually made the company herself sloan
ltd but registered it under jack's name
without him even knowing she could
afford the signature herself or she
could have told him that it's for
something completely legitimate and he
just has no idea and he loves her so he
trusts her so i think this is what's
actually happening i think it's a big
direction trying to make us believe that
jack is the villain and this is just
classic marvel putting somebody so
obviously bad in our face making us
believe that it's the villain when
really it's not but i believe eleanor is
working with kingpin and the tracksuit
mafia helping them launder money i think
it's her behind everything and i could
be completely wrong about this but this
is my theory as of now and i do think
something along these lines is actually
going to happen now the next part we
need to talk about and break down is the
watch the vintage rolex that hawkeye and
the tracksuit mafia are looking for and
this watch is important so important
that laura even asks clint about it
because she knows about it if you
actually listen to what she says when
she speaks in german so where kids can
hear her she says i've been wondering
anything else go missing from the
compound and clint automatically knows
what she's talking about he says do you
mean the rolex and she says yes and
clint gets a little flustered he says uh
i don't think so why wasn't that
destroyed like years ago and laura seems
pretty concerned about this as well and
then she says well i thought so but i
thought the same thing about your fancy
outfit obviously referring to the ronin
outfit which was also at the avengers
compound where the watch was now i have
three ideas of who this watch could
belong to and one of them is it could
belong to laura clinton's the
conversation by saying it's worth
looking into and says if you can check
the signal from the transmitter clearly
hawkeye and his wife laura know all
about this watch they even know and have
the means to track its signal and laura
is showing in the scene that she's not
all what she appears to be she knows
more than one language and she's proven
that she can track a lot of stuff down
whether that's information items and
probably people so i have a theory that
could be pretty far-fetched but hear me
out here clint tells kate the rolex
belongs to somebody that he used to work
with and he says that they've been out
of the game for a long time but their
identity is still attached to that watch
and if the tracksuits find out about it
it would blow their cover goodbye friend
now clint doesn't really have too many
friends so here's my theory the watch is
actually laura's he is talking about his
wife and i think that his wife could
have actually been a spy for another
government now originally i thought that
maybe she was a black widow and when he
pulled out natasha and flipped her
instead of killing her perhaps he did
the same thing with his wife but as some
people pointed out in my stream she's
had kids so she can't be a black widow
unless they have adopted their kids
which is entirely possible so perhaps
laura was a black widow before she fell
in love with hawkeye as he saved her
life instead of killing her along with
natasha and eventually they went on to
adopt some kids and if she was a black
widow then she would have definitely
known natasha as well and probably
worked together and they were probably
really really close which is why their
kids say aunt nat because just like
elena and natasha were sisters laura
could be a somewhat sister to natasha as
well a black widow sister now even if
she's not a black widow she could have
worked with natasha and the black widow
program in some way shape or form and
still could have been pulled out by
clint this would explain the closeness
between natasha and laura because a lot
of people have always thought that it's
kind of weird because it kind of seems
like natasha and clint really really
like each other but perhaps all three of
them just share this bond because clint
was supposed to kill both of them and
didn't but instead gave them a way out
but if this is true then laura
definitely had an identity and just like
natasha's identity and everything she
did was exposed during captain america
the winter soldier perhaps laura is at
risk of that as well which is why she
and clint are both very concerned with
the watch and it not getting into the
wrong hands and revealing the identity
of clint's so-called friend which i
believe is actually her because i don't
think hawkeye would tell kate that it's
her because that would open up a whole
can of worms and kate would want to know
the whole thing and i don't think
hawkeye wants to say yeah it's my wife
she used to be a spy or an assassin and
i'm sure hawkeye just doesn't want to
get into all of that so i'm thinking
that laura showed some pretty good
skills in this episode and she showed a
lot of concern about the watch and so
did clint so it could belong to her
because she could have a past whether
that's being a black widow or spy or
something else they don't want it to get
out now the other option is is it could
literally be a friend of clint now i
don't think it's an avenger because he
would have just said the avengers name
plus all the identities of the avengers
are out there everyone knows tony stark
steve rogers natasha bruce banner these
are public figures people even know thor
who doesn't even live on the planet so i
don't think the watch belonged to an
avenger because none of the avengers
identities are being kept secret so that
leads me to believe that if it's not his
wife his friend could be somebody that
we've never seen before in the mcu it
could perhaps be matt murdock aka
daredevil and the watch could prove that
matt murdock is daredevil which is why
it needs to not fall in the hands of the
wrong people and perhaps clint knows
matt because maybe he helped him out
with some legal stuff after all after
captain america civil war they told us
that clint and scott took plea deals
which means that someone came in and
intervened for them most likely
everyone's entitled to a lawyer so
perhaps that lawyer could have been matt
murdock since matt murdock is rumored to
be in the echo series it would make
sense if he came into this series not to
mention kingpin and echo are directly
related to daredevil so it could be mats
and his daredevil identity could be at
risk here if somebody finds that watch
and if kingpin is behind the tracksuit
mafia which we all believe he is it
would make sense if he believes that
watch belongs to daredevil and could
prove that matt is him or believes it
belongs to matt and could prove that
he's daredevil and my last option would
be kingpin but hawkeye says it belongs
to a friend so i don't believe it could
be kingpin i know a lot of people think
it could be which is why the tracksuit
mafia is trying to get it but i really
doubt it's kingpin's watch so my two
best guesses are it's matt murdock's or
clint's wife has somewhat of a past and
could belong to her now clint actually
went through a lot emotionally in this
episode he revealed to kate that he is
indeed ronan and he did a lot of things
as ronan of course he did this because
his entire family got dusted in the snap
and he kind of starts to relive some
things we see the beginning opening
footage for avengers in-game where
clinton is on his property and he's
teaching his daughter lila how to shoot
a bow laura is making lunch and then of
course they all got snapped and in his
head he hears natasha in the background
saying killing all those people isn't
going to bring your family back which is
what she tells him during avengers in
game we then see new footage of him as
ronin as he relives some parts of his
past as ronan inside of his head we see
him killing a few people which is
obviously haunting him then of course we
see the part of avengers inning game
where natasha sacrifices herself so
clint can get the soul stone which
obviously has been haunting him as well
now clint the next day sends kate on a
mission to go see the larpers the reason
is because the police station has most
of his trick arrows he needs them back
and most of the larpers that he fought
around during the event including grylls
are nypd and firefighters so he needs
kate to get the officers to go to the
precinct and get the arrows so that's
her task and his task is to go and talk
to qazi one of the biggest things that
concerns hawkeye right now is that kate
is in danger because maya thinks that
she's ronan so she's in danger and even
if kate wasn't in danger clint can't
have everybody thinking that the ronin
is still around because that's bad news
for him so he goes to kazi and
essentially tells him hey convince maya
that ronan is gone he's dead and if you
recall in the last episode he actually
said that natasha black widow killed the
ronin now maya didn't believe him and
she actually attacked kate in which kazi
thought was a little overboard which is
why clint is going to kazi he says that
you're a reasonably not stupid person
and he has maya's ear so he tells him to
get the job done convince maya that
ronan is gone and she's chasing a ghost
then hawkeye and kate attempt to break
into an apartment where they have
tracked the location of the rolex
hawkeye has a smart thought out plan but
of course kate kind of goes off the
bandwagon and does things her own way
this puts her inside of the apartment
while clint is on the lookout kate ends
up getting into the apartment where she
immediately sees some lights that are
flashing like strobe lights now she
covers them quickly with putty arrows
and eventually goes on to find the watch
and after she finds the watch she finds
a piece of paper that has information
about clint's family including the name
of his wife and all of their kids so
somebody is tracking down hawkeye and
learning about his family and we quickly
discover that that person is maya clint
quickly realizes that those flashing
strobe lights were sensors for deaf
people the alarms flash for deaf people
since they obviously cannot hear an
alarm now here's where things get really
really good clint thinks that he's
fighting maya on the rooftop and of
course maya comes into the apartment and
hits kate which confuses her because she
says she's fighting maya but clint also
says that he is fighting maya but kate
says no she's here in the apartment and
clinton goes well who the hell am i
fighting a mysterious figure emerges out
of nowhere and fights clint and the
second we see a black widow bite come
off of her wrist we know exactly who it
is it is yelena balova if you've seen
the black widow movie you know exactly
who this is if you haven't seen the
movie it's natasha romanov's sister and
in the post-credits scene of black widow
spoilers incoming we see elena at
natasha's grave when val all of a sudden
comes up to her now we saw val in the
falcon and the winter soldier she
recruited us agent john walker for a
team that hasn't really been revealed
yet but we believe to be the
thunderbolts or the dark avengers and in
the post-credits scene it was very
obvious that she recruited yelena bulova
to work for her and in the scene she
delivers elena's next assignment and she
says that her next assignment is to go
after the person that killed her sister
natasha and then she showed her a
picture of hawkeye so val told yelena
that clint actually killed natasha now
obviously this is a lie but yelena
doesn't know anything else so she kind
of just trusts her employer so this is
why elena shows up out of nowhere and
attacks clint now meanwhile maya and
kate are still fighting but all of them
end up on the same rooftop together in
some scenes that are pretty freaking
awesome all of a sudden we kind of see
everyone fighting maya elena clinton
kate and it's an epic scene until
eventually kate shows up hits everybody
with a sonic arrow in which maya kicks
her clear across the rooftop but then
kate shoots her in the shoulder with an
arrow this causes maya to retreat and
clint is left to deal with yelena in
which she does take her mask off and it
is officially revealed to be yelena
bulova now it looks like she probably
could have taken out clint she hits him
with a widow bite and he kind of goes
down but then kate is looking at her
with a bow pulled back ready to fire an
arrow at her now yelena kind of shakes
her head no and kate does put the arrow
down this causes yolena to make an
escape however i do believe that yelena
could have taken both of them so it
leads me to believe that yelena actually
saw clint taking care of kate and
believes that maybe he's not such a bad
person and could make her question
things now this is where things get
really intense hawkeye recognizes that
that was a black widow and maybe he does
even know who yolina belova is i
wouldn't be surprised considering how
close him and that were and i would
assume yelena knows who hawkeye is
because one he was an avenger and he
fought beside natasha and probably knew
they were at least somewhat friends and
that's enough to put a little bit of
doubt in her mind about whether or not
hawkeye actually did kill her but the
fact that a black widow showed up makes
hawkeye realize how serious this
situation is now a black widow assassin
is now involved in the picture and he
knows because of his experience with
them and natasha that they are some of
the deadliest killers on the planet and
this severely puts kate in jeopardy
hawkeye knew that he could deal with the
tracksuit mafia and keep kate safe but
he doesn't know if he can against a
black widow and this is why he starts to
push her away he does this because he
actually cares for her and doesn't want
her to get hurt he says you're not my
partner you never were and he says i'm
not gonna do it and what he means here
is i'm not gonna partner with you i'm
not gonna risk your life i'm not gonna
have you die he can't go through the
trauma again of losing somebody like
natasha now of course kate doesn't mean
as much to him as natasha he knew her
forever and they were best friends but
of course he is starting to really care
for kate and he can't lose her because
one she's just a kid and two he really
is starting to care for her so he takes
her bow and he tells her to go home and
that is hawkeye episode four please let
me know what you thought about this
episode in the comments down below what
do you rate it from 1 to 10. and let me
know what you think about some of my
theories do you think one of them could
be right or do you have a theory of your
own be sure to put that in the comments
down below as well don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on the mcu and so you can
watch the future breakdowns and for live
updates you can always follow me on
instagram or twitter as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
you